[Musik]
eine schöne frau macht werbung für ein
handy alltag nur dass dieses model kein
mensch ist besteht aus pixeln kreiert am
computer sie und ihre kollegen
revolutionieren gerade die werbe und
modewelt echt oder fake im netz wird es
immer schwieriger das zu erkennen bei
schule und cova immer klar sie sind rein
digitale produkte doch immer öfter
werden auch reale menschen gefegt die
fakes heißen videos und audios die durch
künstliche intelligenz so manipuliert
werden dass die fälschung für laien nur
noch schwer erkennbar ist die plattform
buzzfeed gehörte zu den ersten die
darauf aufmerksam machten
als eindrückliches beispiel diente
barack obama der seinen amtsnachfolger
donald trump einen vollidioten nennt
natürlich alles was es braucht um die
fakes herzustellen sind bilder viele
bilder ein algorithmus analysiert jeden
gesichtsausdruck jedes muskelzucken und
setzt dann etwa mundbewegungen neu
zusammen
so gelingt es das auch lange verstorbene
wie der künstler salvador dalí wieder
auferstehen und chelseas mit
museumsbesuchern machen wie hier in
florida
die schöne seite der die takes you like
möchten sie dass ich ihnen das schicke
doch 96 prozent der dieb fake videos im
netz sind pornographisch und nahezu
immer trifft es frauen berühmte wie
scarlett johansson aber auch unbekannte
die australierin noel martin entdeckte
durch zufall tausende fotos und videos
von sich im netz
jemand hatte ihre facebook fotos
gestohlen und ihren kopf in pornovideos
hinein manipuliert das hat mein leben
massiv erschüttert wenn dir sowas
passiert hat das lebenslange folgen für
deine karriere für deine psychische
gesundheit deine beziehungen zu anderen
menschen
seinen ruf und seine würde martin
versuchte die inhalte löschen zu lassen
vergeblich sie ging an die
öffentlichkeit erreichte dass die
manipulation von bildern in australien
nun verboten ist doch sie kämpft weiter
und soll gesetze sind nur begrenzt
wirksam was wir brauchen ist eine art
globale vorgehensweise denn es kann
nicht sein dass es im 21 jahrhundert
möglich ist dass jemand an seinem laptop
auf der anderen seite der welt sitzt und
die leben von menschen zerstört
facebook hat 2009 10 einen wettbewerb
ausgelobt um eine technik zu entwickeln
die pics aufzuspüren preisgeld zehn
millionen dollar eine ähnliche
initiative kommt vom
us-verteidigungsministerium denn längst
ist klar die pigs bedrohen nicht nur
privatpersonen sondern der
gesellschaftlichen frieden situationen
wieder sturm auf das kapitol könnten
durch deep web videos leicht zu einem
krieg eskalieren befürchten
wissenschaftler zusätzlich zu dieser
politischen polarisierung wo sowieso
schon unterschiedliche gruppen
gegeneinander aufgehetzt sind wenn dann
falschinformationen dazu kommen mit
einer technologie die eine emotionale
ebene anspricht mit audiovisuellen
inhalten weiß nicht haben die
politischen gegner jetzt wird ist als
aufgerufen oder bestimmte dinge gesagt
da ist nicht die das passiert
medienkonsum nicht in einem ruhigen
umfeld wo man schaut was stimmt das
stimmt nicht also da glaube ich kann es
schon sehr verheerende effekte haben
hinzu kommt laut press an die gefahr
dass menschen irgendwann automatisch
davon ausgingen dass medieninhalte
falsch sein
je weniger sie zwischen real und fake
unterscheiden könnten
katastrophal in einer demokratie die
technologie verbieten unrealistisch
längst nutzt die spieleindustrie sie um
avatare der spieler zu erstellen
auch hollywood setzt große hoffnungen in
die technologie denn die cx können eine
faszinierende neue realität erschaffen
schließlich war es noch nie so einfach
david beckham in neun sprachen vor
malaria bahnen zu lassen
[Musik]